all right this is lamb before swine take
two because I didn't have the mic on for
the last one my bad so it was fine by
this one ok this is it works for pegs is
the closing credits thing I bet you're
asking yourself doesn't work for pigs it
does I show what I love about that
commercial is that it starts off with
babies but then the majority of it is
about taking care of pigs I love that
like it just totally is says that all of
the babies I can carry like ten babies
in this thing doesn't work for pigs
you're better does it works for bags oh
so what do we want to talk about that we
already talked about Bergen bobfm bone
ok so this is an episode where Mabel
tell Stan not to put waddles outside he
does a Patera dactyl comes and takes him
away Stan makes up this story that's
life of how we tried to stop him but you
know the Patera Tac Toe got the best of
him
so they chase after it and they find out
that stan was lying and in the end Stan
still saves the day I just realized you
can see my reflection in the TV and it's
only the lights I look like a Christmas
Bush I think that's what is doing stuff
to you I love it
and there's also this story going on
with dipper and soos where dippers are
free not to bring sue so long but suit
cuts oops keyed soos keeps messing up
but he turns out to save the day as well
ok the same message uh so it might be
like it it's fine I mean like I said
I've really seen a bad episode gravity
falls yet it's it is one I can't feel
the message takes over the comedy a
little bit and we know what the message
is going to be very don't leave your Pig
outside if there's anything we can
emphasize don't leave your Pig outside
clearly keep error or predators giant
Patera dactyls I can come and grab them
yes keep them inside where you can eat
him yourself
not that you would care you waddles
hater I don't hate waddles yes you do no
he IMI pig he's only he just doesn't
deliver much he's delivered
two really great things one is the name
waddles because that's an awesome name
two is the opening where Mabel's rubbing
her cheek against his cheek cuz that is
precious that is fucking adorable it is
precious but that's it he has no
identity as no personality there's
nothing else to waddles he's just a pig
he's a minimalist he's austere it's like
a Japanese meal it's just very simple no
no it's not it's it's a nothing it's
there's nothing to him it's just he's a
pickle it's he's just a pig he's a
piglet is it's just a piglet that's why
do you hate all of God's creatures great
and small
I don't just pigs I hate pigs why does
nobody understand my pig hate it because
I hate pigs I hate waddles uh I hate
this episode no it's it's okay honestly
when I saw was coming up I was like oh
this one okay you know if I move around
I'm like the burning bush roses do my
bidding see that's it why don't you
finish the review IIIi don't have much
else uh it's like it's okay I mean it's
not bad it's just like I already talked
about it in length before and I'm not
doing it again
well well thank you for denying the
audience your opinion grunkle Stan was
very funny I liked him writing a Patera
dactyl and mmm fighting off said potato
you know what mcgucket getting eaten by
the baby
Patera dad yes I mention my mentioned
before there was hilarious and I also
remember saying that it was very screwed
up that he ate his way out of that baby
dinosaur well and I'm s fucked up yeah
if that's even what he did for all we
know maybe he just got shit out cuz he
is crying away that's funny yeah it's
pretty fucked up too so ya know I just
love how you can again so the dumb flu
theory you can show anything you want as
long as you have a happy ending a happy
ending for him at least like I said
probably not for the pterodactyl but
poor Patera doc Thorpe a pterodactyl
their only crime was existing or baby
Patera - oh I know I I'm sorry I'm not
gonna be able to get over that that's
just really messed up but we don't know
if that's what he did he's crazy well
well see if the dies are
come back maybe the baby potato actor
will still be there we don't know so
yeah that's about it waddles is a pig
and a nothing a list and you know
welcome for some reason say it again say
it again I dare models is a nothing a
list kill you
wow what a jolly death